hi glamour i'm kaya and this is my
glamour festo for life
[Music]
my daily mantra is today is a new day
that's a good one today is a new day yep
my instant mood
booster is good music um right now i'm
listening to
charlotte lawrence who's a friend but
also just makes great music and she has
a new ep and that's been like
definitely getting my spirits up the
last week i think it's definitely
difficult to manage your mental health
especially with the state of the world
but i've definitely developed some
practices that help like
i write every morning things that i'm
grateful for um things that i can do
to make myself happy today and then i
kind of check back in at the end of the
night and i write
again like things that would have made
today better only things that i can
control though
things that made me happy today things
that i'm grateful for again and
just kind of being conscious of those
things i think has really helped me
manage my mental health
i value loyalty most in my friendships
just a safe space feeling like you can
tell them anything and it will stay
there
and that's something that i really value
i am most looking forward to
one just seeing my friends um also i
think seeing live
music with my friends is something that
i love to do and haven't been able to do
in a long time and i just think that's
something that um will be one of the
first things i try to do when
you know we can alanis morissette was
going on tour and i was very excited for
that and then i couldn't go see her so
if that happens again that will be like
top of my list
i feel my most glam probably doing shows
i would say i feel definitely very
glammed um when i have professionals
doing my hair and makeup
but you know i've learned to feel glam
in
sweatpants at this point so i think it's
all it's a state of mind it's not um
it's not everything else fragrance is
important to me i think one just because
i've been
in the daisy family for so long and it's
just
um it feels like a home to me and it's
become a ritual for me
since i was 14 to wear daisy and so to
be able to evolve with the brand and
just
have it be something that's been
consistent through my whole life i think
has been really wonderful oh so intense
is kind of an interpretation of the
original classic daisy that everyone
knows and loves um
and i love it because i feel like i'm
kind of entering a new phase of my life
so to have this
more like rich intense version of the
daisy that i was wearing
all throughout my teen years um
is really awesome and it just it's
really rich and kind of has a more
intense smell and
it lasts all day so um yeah this i'd say
the corkiest thing i do
is probably my crystals
that i leave outside to charge on the
full moon and then bring back inside and
i'll kind of like lay with them on me or
place them in different areas i'm very
into feng shui and things like that so
i really love rose quartz i just think
it's one that everyone should have
and um it just brings in a lot of really
good energy and that's just one that
i kind of like to have all over yeah i
would say like when i do my
sort of ceremonies with my crystals it's
probably not like the
most normal thing to witness thank you
for watching